hello I'm Jordan Mendoza I'm here with
some of the most popular people on the
Internet at VidCon and I'm here with the
try guys hey guys thanks for having us
okay I look like an idiot you look great
this guy so we get a box and we can
switch places yeah we can put sack by
you yeah that's tiny I'm used to that
this is great
no now you look really small wow you're
making Zach look like an idiot
you guys have millions of views I want
to do exactly what you're doing how do I
become internet popular without having
like much talent at all I mean it's
pretty doable your vids get million of
millions of views how hard does that
make you for example I got 700 followers
this morning and I I went to town by
myself actually I'd say it isn't in the
morning that's a great number 700 more
yeah oh you've got to 700 got to 700
followers on Instagram great follow me
on Instagram okay just take out your
phones and the first person to follow me
on Instagram what kind of wins and then
what's the prize anyone have $20 you
guys tell me the name what's the name oh
yeah
Geordie pizza got it damn I really do
only have 700 followers Wow famous
internet person convention you've got
the 700 hits again your story is it's my
friend Chris Khan in the background
there's almost 2,000 all right you guys
have millions of you I want to do
exactly what you're doing
what other principles are becoming
popular on the Internet where you are
that talent I think you're very I think
you're talented
you're doing tonight but there's a party
mm-hmm mm-hmm I'm sorry no different
goody we're talking yeah I mean I mean
basically like a home shell if that's
later the whole point this convention is
about meeting people meeting in the
lines only fabulous I'm in yeah I'd say
it is a person table so beyond that we'd
be popular I'm Jordan Mendoza this is my
segment and these are my friend hello
the five try guys
we're watching Barry
[Music]